okay so uh let's say he has like
the okatado
okay what what i'm going to do is start
this
fine rotate rotate
so when i'm here like this it'll look
like this
i have x y i'm going to do something a
little different you're going to try one
and you see how i came into this
position
and he went straight and now he's
starting to turn
so the first one i stay here okay here
and the second one right there
if i do yoga that's where my step goes
my step goes there
so it goes through the clinch i don't
clinch them back
i immediately start to turn
start to turn now i can't go ahead again
because he just gets the new straight
line
it's that sweet spot
his intention to try to get me starts
the geometry
it's not me burning him
he's coming to get me and he did it
so there's no effort on my part
there's this timing
[Music]
i don't have to do this
timing
so always deviate before you trap
dva no don't walk in like a zombie dude
let's do it
so
then when i do it
it might look to you like i'm wrestling
him
i'm not it's it's very relaxed isn't it
he pushes i don't do this he pushes
i keep returning he pulls
i enter he pushes turn it
pulls
so i'm not struggling i move
i'm not struggling
move
move it over
this is incorrect
turning enter
so i shouldn't be wrestling which is not
good because wrestlers don't do that
i shouldn't be doing bad wrestling it's
very soft
try okay uh
so when i get here i'll be the
uk okay i'm gonna be the kid
okay so i'm looking for dirty boxing
in fighting jokes do you understand
i'm not looking just to clinch i'm not
going here
okay so it could have been from last
night's technique go home
and pull my overshot okay i'm gonna
boom fight from in here
so i am you don't want me to hit you
okay so find your clinch whatever you
want
okay and he doesn't want me
so you gotta check my height there you
go good
clear look up look at them stronger than
the turn it turns there you go
you didn't come in when i pulled
boom boom
you gotta get my hands
do you like that
it
so i'll do that quiz okay
so hold that pull this out do you think
that's where you are wait don't pull on
my trap
okay find the empty space on my trap
bring your hands there see you can't go
anymore right
so bring the hand to that hand and now
clear it
come inside the grip there you go okay
do it again go
there you go again
good now do it
do you think keep the truck don't have
it just nothing
keep the truck okay keep it
try to get out
do you see where it's trapped okay okay
okay try to try to get out here
watch i'm gonna do this tense up get out
turn out like you're shown yes okay
i'm not gonna tense up go
what's happening i'll tense up go
you see i won't tense up go
you see so you're just trying strength
i'm not doing strength
i'm just doing traps
so i'm not tense
yes here we go
come on clinch
when i do watch it again
where you want that arm to go where do
you want it
can you get in no well watch what i do
it's a trick it's the trunk right go
boom
[Music]
you're getting focused hey over focus
i'm okay
right
boom trap trap good
boom boom
there back
good good so you start to lose this
pull up to the elbow there you go and
relax
watch watch out there you go
i'm pushing turn i'm pulling
enter there you go i push turn
good you got trapped again
so i'm never struggling
do you feel that you're gonna do
something with it right
boom back
so you're gonna be the uh catalyst
you try different things
always finding the empty space
[Music]
good
come on
feel how
[Music]
good
okay so my strategy
is i start that rotation and we'll touch
whatever we touch
so right now um i want you to amplify
i feel his aggression in the spinal
displacement so show it
there i feel that
back here that this he's trying to get
that and i
feel show this hand that and this hand
there okay so i'm going to
turn to the spinal displacement
slide inside
not try to get it
he's in there slide inside
this hand he wants to come down and
maybe go to the head i don't know what
are you trying why are you pushing down
there he goes okay
so he's trying to clear the hand to go
to the head okay
so i don't want to go down and because
i'm going to give him that
but i'll yield
and stick so he's pushing
with his body go back
that's addressed with the turn
this hand's coming in inside
this hand he's going down first right
and then he's coming up
and i stick in a minute
and that's different from me going shoot
and trying to do that he's doing
i
he does another one okay
i i feel you there do you feel that
i feel your shoulder there and i feel
this cup
here and this elbow trying to get me
here
you see that okay so rather than
push back try to get that thing
i agree the same thing he goes
i'm gonna do you feel that feel my
resistance okay
he goes i change the angle you see
see what's happening to you now okay so
you're going to want to go this way now
right
so he goes that way and
i'll turn again
he goes start the rotation there
it's right here you feel it okay so he
goes
i'll take it away
[Music]
coming again boom
again go go do whatever you want
again
so
to me that's different than this
i have to be stronger than him these are
all
letting him do it he's pushing
[Music]
he's trapping right there did you feel
it
whose arm must go like that let me go
like that
so feel the resistance it's right here
you see inside
right here
go
right here oh not a good one keep going
good push here
so in my training feel
she is cup don't pull it out
find it in find it in
can feel that it's not here
here
it's not struggling whether i'm close
or far it's struggling whether i'm young
against
[Music]
so this is just
reconciling those energies
this would be all get strong
okay try it so start the rotation
he's driving at me
so you push it i have the heels
but you can see i'm on the other side of
the center line already
so the kazushi pattern is right here
start the rotation he's driving
this hand is still doing it
slight adjustment and then tire turned
inside of his turn
he's pushing me whoa
here this way
same thing wait for the drive well
there's the drive
you need me 10 pumps down here
boom you just do you all finish
okay
here oh there boom
did you drive
[Music]
okay